monsieur Gilles Moreton président de la
Fédération française de tennis et Madame
Caroline flessier directrice générale
madame monsieur je vous souhaite la
bienvenue et vous remercie de votre
disponibilité pour répondre à nos
questions nous avons entamé les travaux
de cette commission d'enquête sur
l'identification des défaillances de
fonctionnement au sein des fédérations
françaises de sport du monde sportif et
des organismes de gouvernance du monde
sportif le 20 juillet dernier
l'Assemblée nationale a décidé de sa
création à la suite de très nombreux
révélation publique de sportives et
sportifs et de diverses affaires
judiciaires ayant tras à la gestion de
certaines fédérations nos travaux porent
sur trois axes les violences physiques
sexuelles ou psychologiques dans le
sport les discriminations sexuelles et
raciales et les problématiques liées à
la gouvernance financière des organismes
de gouvernance du monde sportif monsieur
vous présidez la FFT depuis février 2021
avant cela vous exerciez des fonctions
de bénévole au sein de la FFT vous avez
présidé de 2000 201 à 2021 la Ligue
oververn ronalp pouvez-vous dans un
court propos liminire nous indiquer les
faits dont vous avez eu connaissance
dans le périmètrre qui intéresse notre
commission et les réponses qui ont été
apportées quelle est la politique menée
par la Fédération dans ces domaines
pouvez-vous faire le point sur la mise
en œuvre des recommandations qui ont été
formulées à l'égard de la FFT par les
autorités de contrôle en part en
particulier l'igesr qui a effectué un
contrôle en 2022 je rappelle que cette
audition est ouverte à la presse et est
retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale afin avant de vous
laisser la parole et d'entamer nos
échanges pendant environ 1h30 je vous
rappelle que l'article 6 de l'ordonnance
du 17 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires impose aux personnees
entendu par une commission d'enquête de
prêter serment de dire la vérité toute
la vérité rien que la vérité je vous
invite donc à lever la main droite et à
dire chacun à votre tour je le jure
après avoir activé votre
micro
alors chacun vot
tour je le jure il faut éteindre pour
que ça puisse fonctionner je le jure
très bien je vous laisse 5 à 10 minutes
de propos liminires et puis ensuite on
échangera par
question très bien bien merci merci
beaucoup merci de de nous accueillir on
est on est ravi de
venir nous exprimer auprès auprès de
vous aujourd'hui euh tout d'abord si
vous le permettez je je vais vous
présenter la Fédération Française de
Tennis vous avez présenté un petit peu
mon mon parcours avant d'arriver à la
tête de la Fédération française de
tennis en tant que bénévole
effectivement alors je je vais même
apporter une un complément en tant que
retraité euh à la tête puisque on on il
y a un sujet qui est important aussi et
qui va concerner t tous vos travaux
c'est c'est la relation avec les
bénévoles dans nos fédérations euh et
donc moi j'ai eu la chance de de d'être
président d'une ligue auvern runalp et
et et d'apprendre un peu le
fonctionnement interne d'une fédération
et et puis ensuite d'être élu à la
Fédération notre notre sport la
Fédération française de tennis c'est CIN
pratiques c'est quatre raquettes alors
les pratiques c'est le tennis le Padel
le beach tennis la courte paume et le
tennis fauteuil donc ça ce sont les cinq
pratiques avec quatre raquettes
différentes bien évidemment le tennis et
le tennis fauteuil se pratique avec des
raquettes nous avons un lion 100000 un
peu plus de 100on 100000 licenciés en
2023 donc exercice se terminant fin août
c'est donc 7 plus de 7000 clubs de
partout en France c'est 100000 bénévoles
dans dans nos villes partic
particularité à notre fédération c'est
que nous sommes propriétaires de de
d'événements sportifs de grands
événements sportifs je pense à Roland
Garros et et tout bientôt dès lundi
prochain le Rolex Paris Masters ici à
Paris propriét é donc c'est assez rare
que des fédérations soient propriétaires
si je compare un événement français
majeur le Tour de France cycliste
appartient pas à la Fédération française
mais appartient à une société
commerciale la Fédération française de
tennis c'est une fédération qui fait
plus de 400 millions d'Uros de chiffre
d'affaires en 2023 c'est
460 équivalent temps plein ici sur sur
le siège c'est plus de 800 personnes sur
le territoire donc salariés des comités
départementaux et des ligues et donc
avec une particularité pour notre
fédération et et je vais rentrer dans un
domaine d'explication de notre sport qui
va toucher directement les sujets
évoqués aujourd'hui c'est la
caractéristique d'un sport qu'il faut
prendre en compte pour lutter contre les
violences sexuelles et sexistes entre
autres c'est un sport individuel alors
si je peux me permettre j'ai aussi un
parcours où j'ai où j'ai vécu de
l'intérieur tout ça puisque j'ai une
première prère vie où j'ai été joueur de
tennis professionnel j'ai été enseignant
de tennis après et puis ensuite chef
d'entreprise avant d'être retraité et de
m'occuper de ma fédération c'est d'abord
un sport
individuel c'est un sport qui a un
rapport avec le coach avec l'entraîneur
qui est très important c'est d'abord
aussi pour nous un sujet d'isolement
souvent puisque nous avons un un rôle
qui est différent d'autres
fédérations la Fédération française de
tennis est amenée à faire dans les
territoires dans les clubs de la
détection euh de la formation d'autres
fédération fonctionne différemment je
vais penser à au foot par exemple où la
détection est faite beaucoup par les
clubs professionnels qui font ce rôle de
détection et dès qu'un jeune fonctionne
bien il est appé par les clubs
professionnels et nous avons nous cette
cette particularité euh on a une
exposition au risqu euh qui est
importante de de Man manipulation des
compétitions sportives et je vais faire
un parallèle et c'est important de
comprendre notre fédération au monde il
y a environ 200 à 250 joueurs qui vivent
du tennis en tant que professionnel 200
à 250 même chose je fais une comparaison
avec d'autres sports professionnels
comme le foot en France en France vous
avez plus de 2000 joueurs qui déjà
simplement la France qui vivent de leur
sport professionnel donc nous il y a
très peu d'élus alors peut-être que les
meilleur gagnent beaucoup d'argent mais
pour vivre du tennis c'est très
compliqué ce qui veut dire que on a on a
une pyramide qui est assez compliqué
pour accéder au haut niveau et très très
peu d'élus arrivent au au bout alors
concernant et je vais peut-être laisser
à Caroline le soin de vous présenter
concrètement les actions que nous menons
au sein de la
fédération
concernant le les ces caractéristiques
donc qui sont à prendre en compte pour
lutter contre les violences sexistes et
et sexuel vous avez reçu des des gens
ici qui ont
été concernés hein de la Fédération
française de tennis sur lequel nous
avons effectivement été amené à traiter
on fait très sincèrement je dirais
malheureusement beaucoup de choses
puisque un des premiers cas révélés est
un cas d'une d'une joueuse de tennis et
et je suis ravi aujourd'hui de de dire
que la Fédération sous notre mandat a
pris vraiment fait t causes pour pour
ces cas-là et notamment dans la Recon
instuction qui est un sujet important
mais je vais laisser à Caroline le soin
d'expliquer dans le détail ce que nous
faisons sur ce
sujetl donc comme le disait le président
le bah le le sujet en tout cas le la
tout ce qui lutte contre les violences
sex sexuelles et toute forme de
harcèlement et notre priorité en fait à
la Fédération Française de Tennis on a
une politique qui est très simple
politique tolérance zéro et pour ça donc
on on se dote de de moyens les moyens
qu'on a aujourd'hui donc nous avons créé
une structure dédiée à l'intégrité
sportive en
2019 dans cette structure donc travail
deux personnes à pleintemps et un
contrat
d'apprentissage nous avons également
désigné 18 référents intégrités sportif
dans dans dans chacune de nos ligues
donc tout ça pour pour mailler le mieux
possible notre territoire et et et
pouvoir déployer l'ensemble de nos
programmes donc on a des des programmes
dédiés je je sais que vous en avez
connaissance avec des associations
l'association de d'Isabelle de monjot et
puis l'association rebond euh avec
Angélique Kochi que vous avez auditionné
et puis on met en place en fait donc on
met à disposition de nombreuses
ressources pour les victimes les
encadrant les clubs et les organes
décentralisés on a par exemple une page
d'information dédiée à la protection des
mineurs sur le site de la Fédération on
a également un formulaire de signalement
on a des affiches dédiés donc des quites
de communication et des affiches dédié à
la prévention donc des atteintes à
l'intégrité sportive que l'on l'on
partage et qu'on diffuse à l'ensemble de
nos acteurs en fait des acteurs de
l'écosystème du du tennis des principes
de bonne conduite pour les encadrants
sportifs et puis on a mis en place en
fait en septembre 2022 une assurance
protection juridique des victimes de
violence sexuelle je crois que angélique
Kochi vous en avez parlé et donc là
c'est pour pour tout licencier en fait
l'accès à une protection juridique et
donc un acc accpagnement bah voilà un
accompagnement financier en fait pour
pouvoir aider les les victimes à
supporter leur leurs frais juridique et
même un accompagnement psychologique
nous onons également beaucoup d'actions
de de
sensibilisation des formations en fait
présentielles ou ou en ligne on a un
module de formation de protection des
des mineurs qui est intégré à notre
plateforme de de formation et intégré au
référentiel des formations diplômantes
on a également on organise des
séminaires de sensibilisation et de
formation auprès de l'ensemble de nos
populations sur l'ensemble du territoire
en 2024 donc on a on a des tournées en
fait qui sont planifiées avec une
vingtaine de de dates par exemple on a
organiser donc un une une conférence en
2022 sur la réparation en fait la
réparation donc pouvoir accompagner et
comprendre en fait comment comment
réparer après un un un tel un tel drame
et puis
on a mis en place donc des chartes alors
on a mis en place une charte en fait
pour l'ensemble de nos
référents et et enfin donc pour l'année
2024 en fait on on a le déploiement
d'une plateforme de suivi sociau
professionnel en fait pour l'ensemble de
nos de sportifs avec des modules dédiés
à l'intégrité sportive donc ça c'est
c'est c'est c'est un ensemble d'actions
que l'on met en place et puis avec en
complément des campagnes de de
régularisation des courriers qui sont
envoyés à l'ensemble de l'écosystème
pour expliquer ce qu'on fait l'année en
février de cette année euh nous avons
envoyé un courrier à plus de
16000 personnes acteurs de notre
écosystème pour rappeler nos actions
pour les inciter pour rappeler
l'existence de nos plateformes de
signalement et cetera donc on on fait
énormément de choses sur bah sur ce
sujet qui encore une fois est notre
priorité avec une politique tolérance
zéro
oui vas-y vas-y ah pardon
ajouter excusez-moi j'ai peut-être ajoué
deux choses sur le sujet parce que on
vous a parlé moi je vais vous décrire
carrément parce que je je me considère
moi comme un plus comme un président de
terrain qu'un président de salon et
quand on parle des actions menées sur le
terrain c'est carrément lorsqu'on a des
rassemblements de jeunes on a un tournoi
par exemple qui s'appelle les petits ass
à Tarbe où les les meilleurs viennent
jouer ce sont des U1 avec ophéli soudre
qui est en charge chez nous
effectivement de de de la
tout ce qui touche à l'intégrité on est
allé parler à la fois au aux enfants
donc aux joueurs en direct sans sans les
parents sans personne pour leur
expliquer concrètement qu'est-ce qu'il
pouvaient accepter ou ne pouvaiit pas
accepter qu'un entraîneur Vienne dans la
chambre à partir de 9h alors on on est
on on est dans ce sport individuel où la
relation entre entraîneur entraîné est
très forte on a euh mis en place des
règles où se serrer se serrer fort après
une victoire ne ne doit pas être quelque
chose de d'acquis voilà expliquer que il
y avait des limites au comportement
humain entre un entraîneur et et les
entraîner donc les jeunes ont été très
in intéressés la remarque qu'ils nous
ont fait c'est que d'abord ils étaient
au courant par leurs parents donc
c'était intéressant et puis derrière
nous avons fait la même réunion avec les
entraîneurs seuls euh et avec
probablement peut-être des prédateurs à
l'intérieur j'appelle ça des prédateurs
mais au moins ils savent aujourd'hui
dans le tennis que nous sommes là nous
sommes là sur le le terrain et tout à
l'heure quand Caroline parlait d'action
menée c'est ce type j'étais là moi sur
cette ces rassemblements pour écouter à
la fois les enfants d'un côté les
parents et aussi les entraîneurs
s'exprimai par rapport à cette situation
puis derrière je voudrais parler deux
mots de d'Isabelle de Monjour parce que
j'étais avec elle sur le terrain il y a
2 jours sur de l'Urban tennis parce que
notre philosophie nous est de permettre
au plus grand nombre de jouer au tennis
hein le tennis se pratique je dirais
presque malheureusement que dans des
clubs affiliés à la Fédération si demain
vous le tennis bah vous pouvez pas jouer
parce que vous devez aller dans un club
nous nous avons lancé l'Urban tennis et
on construit on met en place des petits
cours avec des petites raquettes des
balles Mouss de façon à ce que tout le
monde pu avoir accès et donc pour
revenir à Isabelle de monjau dans la
reconstruction que lorsque j'ai vu
Isabelle avant mon mandat que je
connaissais bien puisque c'est une
ancienne joueuse comme moi j'ai vraiment
découvert une personne qui était
détruite et je crois que la Fédération
dans son cas a fait un travail de
reconstruction à la fois elle témoin
elle fait des conférences elle s'exprime
elle nous fait on a des tutos où elle
explique ce qu'on doit faire ce qu'on
doit pas faire et d'un autre côté elle
est elle voulait reprendre son rôle
d'entraîneur de joueuse de tennis et et
donc je suis ravi moi qu'elle ait pu se
reconstruire elle est je le trouve
épanouie maintenant et j'en suis en tout
cas très très heureux pour elle je vais
peut-être toucher un petit mot si
Caroline tu permets sur l'intégrité sur
les les compétitions puisque ça fait
partie bien évidemment des des sujets
tout à l'heure je voulais dire très peu
de joueurs de Ten vivent du tennis au
monde donc c'est même pas en France et
donc sur l'intégrité on a une lutte
contre les risques de manipulation sur
les compétitions sportives dans le cadre
notamment des paris sportifs et ça ça a
été engagé très tôt et il y a
effectivement des cas et des affaire
alors je vais pas dire que ceci explique
ce ça cela c'estàd qu'on a peu de
joueurs qui gagnent de l'argent donc ils
sont incités parfois à à à franchir la
ligne le sport c'est un sport individuel
est nomade c'est chacun est indépendant
on a ses joueurs qui circule dans le
monde entier et en fait très tôt la
Fédération Française de Tennis s s'est
positionné dans son action contre unebê
en 2009 donc c'est c'est c'est déjà
vieux c'est un cas qui a fait
jurisprudence avant que la loi de 2010
consacre les le droit au Paris dans le
cadre du droit de propriété des
organisateurs d'événements sportifs on a
un large Arsenal d'action qu'on a
déployé au sein de la Fédération
Française d'abord la
détection sur les actions qui sont
menées hein c'est d'abord des
observateurs nous avons des observateurs
qui sont sur les alors c'est sur les
grands tournois que les paris se font
mais pas seulement hein c'est souvent
sur des tout petits tournoi où on peut
parier sur le vainqueur à la fin d'un
set ou et cetera donc on a des
observateurs qui sont là pour voir le
comportement on a aussi une
sensibilisation notamment sur les grands
tournois comme Roland Garros ou le Rolex
Paris Masters auprès des joueurs des
cadres de l'entourage des familles hein
c'est environ sur Roland garot c'est
environ
600 créditation avec une charte qui est
qui qui est mise en place et puis aussi
on a alors c'est tout récent et nous
sommes le premier tournoi à l'avoir fait
au monde on a on a engagé on a passé un
accord avec une société qui s'appelle
bodyguard alors comme son nom l'indique
c'est c'est effectivement une société de
protection mais protection contre contre
les les attaques que peuvent subir des
joueurs de tennis sur les paris sportifs
donc ça c'est quelque chose que nous
avons mis en place avec avec succès
concernant l'éthique je crois que c'est
c'est un sujet aussi important si vous
le permettez Caroline alors donc on a on
est doté d'un
comité donc nous sommes dotés d'un d'un
comité d'éthique de déontologie et
traitement des conflits d'intérêts nous
avons également une procédure procédure
d'alerte pardon et une charte éthique
donc la la sachez que le comité
d'éthique a été créé en 2017 et donc
c'est une instance composée de de de six
membres et et qui peut s'autoaisir qui
peut être saisi par tout licencié
parents licencié mineur ou par tout
lanceur d'alerte par également donc les
les dirigeants de la Fédération des
comités de ligue ont l'obligation de
saisir le comité d'éthique pour toute
question en fait et tout tout sujet
éthique dont ils auraient connaissance
c'est un un comité en fait qui décide
librement du contenu de ses publications
en ligne donc il y a un pouvoir de de
publication au-delà de de son rôle de
conseil c'est un comité qui a traité
plus d'une centaines de cesines depuis
depuis sa création en 2017
et c'est un comité avec lequel nous
travaillons en fait régulièrement et sur
lequel nous pouvons nous appuyer en cas
de de questionnement ou ou ou de voilà
de sujets un petit peu plus complexe
concernant la gouvernance et la vie
démocratique de la Fédération peut-être
je ouis on va on déborde un peu mais je
crois que c'est important aussi de vous
expliquer la au niveau de la gouvernance
et vie démocratique au sein de la
Fédération Française de tennis d'abord
on a modifie modifié en 2023 en
profondeur les statuts de la fédération
Française de Tennis d'abord et par par
la loi par le vote des clubs hein qui
seront donc à hauteur de de 50 % avec le
la voix des délégués avec une euh un
comité une mixité importante puisque il
y aura la parité à la Fédération
française de tennis sur le plan national
en 2024 et la parité sera mise en place
en 2028 dans les régions euh sujet de la
la
représentation dans la le comité fédéral
qui est l'organe de décision ce qui
n'est pas le cas actuellement donc c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons
modifié les statuts aujourd'hui nous
avons un Comex le Comex a été instauré
par l'équipe précédente au sein de la
fédération ce comité exécutif est
composé de membres d'une seule liste de
la liste du vainqueur alors que nous
avons mis en place et c'était aussi dans
dans les le projet de de de campagne que
nous avions pour arriver à la Fédération
Française de Tennis c'est un comité
fédéral ce comité fédéral sera euh bien
évidemment composé euh des différentes
listes qui seront présentes et
différentes tendances voilà et peut-être
en guise et on a débordé mais en guise
de conclusion moi je voudrais simplement
et je l'ai je l'ai dit en en préambule
vous dire un petit mot sur euh sur le
sport et sur le sport d'une fédération
qui repose beaucoup euh sur le bénévolat
euh je crois qu'il faut absolument
protéger les pratiquants à protéger les
enfants avant tout en priorité mais
aussi mais aussi protéger les bénévoles
qui sont dans ce sont eux qui à qui on
demande beaucoup et qui demandent vont
apporter des réponses à vos questions
qui sont des questions importantes et
les questions que vous soulevez et si ce
sont dans nos clubs les premiers à mener
les alertes ou à mettre en place des
choses ce sont les bénévoles dans nos
clubs et je crois qu'il faut absolument
s'en
préoccuper
merci à vous deux pour ce propos
liminire euh alors comme vous vous en
doutez on a énormément de questions pour
vous
euh je vais peut-être commencer par
finalement
euh je vais peut-être repartir du
témoignage d'Angélique Kochi qu'on a eu
l'occasion donc d'entendre dans le cadre
de cette commission et de certains
éléments qu'elle avait pu porter à notre
connaissance à ce moment-là
euh donc d'abord je on a vu que vous
aviez une une plateforme de signalement
qui était propre à la Fédération de
tennis euh sur laquelle vous indiquez
euh pour toute information
complémentaire et euh nous vous
informons vous avez toujours la
possibilité de contacter la cellule
signal sport
euh nous on aimerait juste comprendre
pourquoi est-ce que vous n'indiquez pas
clairement euh que les victimes peuvent
directement témoigner auprès de la
cellule signal sport parce qu'en fait ça
passe par votre plateforme ensuite
est-ce que comment c'est traité en
interne de la Fédération est-ce qu'il y
a d'abord un prétraitement et ensuite
c'est renvoyé sur signal sport est-ce
que vous traiter en interne euh comment
ça se passe puisque on sait qu'il y a eu
quelques confusions parfois euh sur
l'utilisation de cette cellule signal
sport donc comment est-ce que ça
fonctionne à la Fédération de
tennis vas-y tu ve je te laisse démarer
donc en effet en fait il y il y a
plusieurs manières de de faire un
signalement et euh nous on a on a cette
politique qui est de dire il faut que ce
soit simple il faut que ce soit
accessible et certains vont vont aller
sur notre PL notre notre notre
formulaire de signalement et d'autres
sur la Form sur la la plateforme signal
sport aujourd'hui on travaille de
manière très rapprochée avec avec signal
signal sport puisque sur on a
97 signalement qu' ont été que bah que
nous avons reçu depuis le depuis le la
création de de notre cellule intégrité
sur ces 8 17 dossiers en fait on en a à
peu près une cinquantaine qui sont
partagés avec signal sport sachant que
voilà il y il y a des dossiers aussi qui
ne sont qui ne sont pas de l'ordre des
des violences sexuelles et sexistes donc
donc les 50 Dossiers c'est des VSS oui
exactement et on en a on a une
quarantaine à peu près qu'on a qu'on a
transmis à Signal sport et une quinzaine
qui viennent de est-ce que signal sport
reçoit des témoignages en dehors de
votre plateforme qui vous sont transmis
une quinzaine on en a reçu 14 je crois
je je je vous prépare des mais est-ce
que vous ne pensez pas que ça prête à
confusion de mettre pour toute
information complémentaire et de ne pas
en fait spécifiquement indiquer que la
victime peut directement saisir la
cellule signal sport alors je vais vous
faire par de témoignage parce que c'est
pas aussi cartésien que que vous le
présentez moi j'ai des joueuses qui sont
venus me voir directement moi ni signal
sport ni notre cellule donc ça veut dire
que il y a des cas particul parulier on
peut pas d'abord on sait pas où sont les
cas de quelle manière les personnes
réagissent moi lorsque j'ai reçu ces
personnes je les ai reçu en disant voilà
quand tu veux si tu veux on a à
l'intérieur de la Fédération une
personne au féissoudre tu peux
aller la voir tu peux aussi aller voir
signal sport directement et ça s'est
fait pas tout de suite parce que la
personne n'était pas mûre pour le faire
et cetera voilà donc on il y a pas je
pense que c'est compliqué de dire voilà
il faut qu'il y ait une règle je pense
que ça fonctionne très bien avec signal
sport aujourd'hui et que nous à la
limite plus on est à l'écoute du
territoire à l'écoute des problématiques
plus on peut y répondre et orienter
peut-être de façon différentes à chaque
fois parce que les cas sont à chaque
fois différents et les personnalités que
nous avons en face sont sont chaque fois
différentes alors j'entends parfaitement
c'est pas tellement enfin c'est c'est
pas le fait de de poser une règle c'est
juste que dans le cadre des travaux de
cette commission on s'est aperçu que
l'information autour de la cellule
signal sport n'était pas euh en fait
était mal fait ou alors incompris euh
que ce soit à l'INSP qu'on a eu
l'occasion d'y aller ou effectivement il
n était inscrit nulle part que les
victimes pouvaient saisir directement la
cellule et là en l'occurrence dans
l'information que vous mettez euh c'est
le cas aussi c'est-à-dire que vous
mettez pour information complémentaire
mais il n'est pas indiqué que la victime
peut saisir directement la cellule bien
sûr que les victimes elles choisissent
le canal par lequel elles veulent
s'exprimer mais notre rôle à nous en
tout cas le rôle Desf ération et et des
instituts et de donner la bonne
information et ensuite la victime s'en
saisit ou pas et en l'occurrence si on
n'indique pas même si vous le faites à
l'oral quand les victimes viennent vous
voir mais si ce n'est pas inscrit
quelque part qu'elles peuvent saisir
directement la cellule signal sport
c'est un déficit d'information et on
s'en est rendu compte ici la plupart des
gens qu'on a auditionné ne connaissaient
pas signal sport ça fait 3 ans que ça
existe elles n'en connaissaiit ni ni
l'existence et elle n'avait pas
d'information sur cette cellule c'est
juste ça que j'essaie de de de
comprendre et voilà pour qu'on puisse
justement peut-être faire des
préconisations très précises sur comment
informer autour de cette cellule et
indiquer au plus grand nombre de
personnes qui sont au sein de ce
mouvement sportif qu'elles peuvent
directement saisir la cellule sans
forcément passer par leur fédération
oui alors je pense que sur ce
que sur ce qu'on vous a présenté on a
effectivement Caroline vous a décrit un
petit peu tout ce qu'on peut faire à la
fois dans les territoires on a des
référents on a mis des affiches on a mis
on est sur le terrain de façon après la
la lecture de tout ce qu'on peut faire
et et on on peut difficilement se mettre
à la place des personnes je pense que
nous au niveau de la Fédération on a
fait on fait beaucoup de choses
peut-être pas assez hein d'ailleurs
c'est c'est la raison pour laquelle on
est là et on est prêt à écouter mais je
pense qu'on fait on a fait beaucoup de
façon à ce que très vite les personnes
les parents les entraîneurs les les les
victimes soient capables de de saisir
signal sport sans avoir à passer
peut-être par par mon bureau ou autre
vous avez raison on a fait pas mal de
choses est-ce que c'est suffisant c'est
c'est le sujet nous je pense que sur le
terrain concrètement dans nos clubs là
où se trouve le problème parce que le
problème il est à la base he pas
forcément dans le haut niveau mais à la
base lorsqu'on a on a eu cette volonté
d'aller
vraiment dire en proximité pour pour
informer et et signaler que on il y a un
système qui fonctionne alors euh
ok alors
deux questions du coup est-ce que le
ministère des Sports vous
a donné des consignes pour communiquer
autour de signal sport c'estàd est-ce
que vous avez des plaquettes de
communication d'information que vous
transmet le ministère des Sports pour
informer sur la cellule signal sport
parce que juste je rappelle
vraiment à la base je crois signal sport
a été justement mis en place pour éviter
que les fédération ne fasse un filtre
sur les signalements et les témoignages
et d'ailleurs ça s'est ressenti ici
quand on a reçu des victimes elles
indiquaient systématiquement qu'ell
n'avait pas confiance parce que c'était
en hclos parce que tout le monde se
connaît parce que finalement sur
certaines affaires tout le monde était
au courant mais personne n'a jamais rien
dit et donc c'était aussi pour sortir
des fédérations et des clubs qu'on a
créer un outil rattaché au ministère des
sport pour que les victimes puissent
directement s'en saisir et donc si vous
voulez la difficulté c'est que si on
nindique pas aux sportifs qu'ils peuvent
saisir la cellule sans passer par le
filtre de la Fédération bah ça devient
en fait on perd l'essence même de
pourquoi on a créé signal sport donc
voilà c'est pour ça que j'essaie de
comprendre pourquoi vous avez fait ce
choix et donc est-ce que le ministère
lui ne vous donne pas des plaquettes
d'information à disposition justement
des licenciés de votre
fédération donc tout à fait oui on est
on travaille en collaboration étroite
avec le ministère et c'est vrai qu'on a
on a cette équipe qui est dédié en fait
à l'intégrité sportive et qui échange
régulièrement avec le ministère nous
notre notre responsabilité c'est
vraiment d'informer le mieux possible
bah nos nos licenciés nos pratiquants et
cetera donc en terme de visibilité on
est d'accord si on peut faire quelque
chose pour pour bah pour rendre la
cellule pour rendre signal sport plus
visible évidemment on le fera moi on
prend votre point sur sur nos affichages
il y a pas du tout de on n'est pas en
compétition du tout avec signal sport on
travaille avec eux ça se passe très très
bien aujourd'hui on est cette cellule
est très utile aussi et et encore une
fois comme le disait le Président il
faut qu'il y ait plusieurs manières de
faire et que ce soit très lisible et
très simple donc c'est c'est vraiment
notre notre
intention si on peut faire quelque chose
pour la visibilité signal sport on le
fera évidemment
oui alors justement pour qu'il y ait
plusieurs manières de le faire il faut
que ça soit clairement indiqué voilà
donc si on nindique pas que la victime
peut saisir sans passer par le fil de la
Fédération euh voilà pour pour votre
information en fait on est en train de
de faire un motion design donc une voilà
une un petit film pour expliquer aussi
et puis pour alerter sur sur les
violence et et et et donc on a aussi
benah nous aussi on on s'améliore
d'année en année sur notre communication
sur la manière d'adresser le sujet et en
effet le signal sport fait partie des
bah des plateformes en fait qu'on
indique très bien alors
euh au moment de du propos introductif
vous avez indiqué parce que c'était
revenu au moment notamment de l'audition
d'Angélique Kochi sur la question des
chambres d'hôtel avec donc les joueurs
de tennis qui partent parfois avec leur
avec leur entraîneur donc avait été
évoqué le fait que enfin voilà il y
avait souvf à l'époque en tout cas de
cette affaire les entraîneurs
partageaient la chambre de des joueurs
de tennis c'était connu par tous les
entraîneurs et les adultes qui étaient
présents et personne n trouvait rien à
redire vous avez dit quelque chose qui
nous a un peu interpeller c'est que vous
avez dit on a indiqué euh à tout le
monde que l'entraîneur à partir de 9h ne
pouvait ne pouvait pas aller dans dans
la chambre de d'un d'un jeune ça veut
dire qu'avant 9h il peut y aller enfin
juste faudrait préciser votre votre
pensée là-dessus on a été c'est bien
c'est bien d'être précis on a été
effectivement amené à à expliquer
alorsement je sais pas si c'est 9h je je
voudrais je voudrais j'ai peut-être été
pas très précis là-dessus mais euh je
pense qu'on sera tout à fait capable
avec auhéissou de vous dire moi j'ai
j'étais là lorsque'on a fait cette
présentation sur les petits assatares
mais ce qui est fait à chaque fois pour
expliquer que les les les limites qui
sont à à respecter tout à l'heure je
parlais de d'embrasser de serrer on a
une victoire on sert dans les bras et
cetera il y a des choses qui sont pas
naturelles et qu'on a donc on a
mentionné un certain nombre de choses
qui effectivement vous avez raison
probablement été été pratiqué par le le
passé où les chambres étaient partagées
par par les entraîneurs alors souvent et
tout à l'heure je voulais expliquer
c'était c'est pas du tout une une excuse
mais les les les les le souci financier
autour du tennis autour du circuit
professionnel ça c'est c'est assez
important faisait que des joue des des
des entraîneurs voyageaient et parfois
étaient amenés à partager donc ça
c'était juste inacceptable et les choses
malheureusement bah puisqueon on a
hérité d'un certain nombre de cas c'est
que les choses se faisait probablement
et là on a on a fixé un certain nombre
de de limites de règles alors je serai
plus précis la prochaine fois je vous
prie de m'excuser alors juste pour
préciser du coup on va prendre le
problème à l'envers à l'envers qu'est-ce
qui justifierait qu'un entraîneur aille
dans la chambre d'un jeune sportif à
n'importe quel moment de la journée ou
de la nuit alors ce qui pourrait
justifier alors de de la nuit aucune
raison quand on prépare un match on peut
le préparer en vidéo on peut on peut le
travailler sur le joueur que l'on va
jouer il peut on peut passer du temps
ensemble en en one to un contre un à
discuter échanger et on pourrait
imaginer que ça se fasse ailleurs mais
ça je pense qu'il ne faut pas juste
pardon excusez-moi mais je pense qu'il
faut pas juste l'imaginer en fait je
crois que justement c'est là o on est
vraiment dans le cœur de ce qui a posé
problème pendant des années je pense
qu'il n'y a aucune raison à aucun moment
pour qu'un adulte rentre dans la chambre
d'un mineur ou d'ailleurs d'un d'un
majeur lorsqu'il est sous son
autorité pour préparer quoi que ce soit
il faut travailler à ce que cela ne se
fasse plus et trouver des endroits
neutres où ils peuvent préparer les
entraînements ou d'autres choses enfin
je sais pas pour ce que les uns et les
autres en pensent mais je crois que moi
en tant que parent je n'accepterai
jamais qu'un adulte entre dans la
chambre de mon enfant pour quelque
raison que ce soit oui tout à fait donc
on a là on a on a une donc on dans la la
charte des encadrants il est bien
spécifié donc il y a pas d'horaire
concernant concernant les chambres euh
il y a parfois nécessité de voilà de
frapper donc il est bien un inscrit donc
on frappe on s'annonce et évidemment
parfois bah quand c'est l'heure de
partir voilà il y a une question de
rangement des chambres et cetera donc ça
c'est des choses qui sont faites il est
spécifié qu'il faut garder la porte
ouverte que les réunions doivent être
faites dans des parties commune autant
que de possible parce qu' après il y a
il y a un principe de réalité c'est
qu'en fonction des hôtels où ils sont
euh voilà
parfois ben il est nécessaire de
rappeler qu'il faut mieux faire ça dans
le dans le hall d'entrée que que dans
une chambre et et donc voilà on a toute
une liste en fait de de de points alors
juste si je peux me permettre de
préciser je pense qu'au lieu d'inscrire
enfin au lieu de dire il vaut mieux
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas qu'il faut
rendre
obligatoire le fait que cela se fasse
ailleurs que dans la chambre
ou si tout à fait ouais non mais c'est
important en fait par vaut mieux mais en
fait il vaut mieux c'est c'est une
option h voilà
c'est les mots sont importants bien
sûr alors peut-être sur la question de
l'isolement toujours on a évoqué enfin a
été évoqué la question des équipements
sportifs et
notamment les terrains de tennis tels
qui sont agencés est-ce que là aussi il
y a une réflexion sur le le fait
d'éviter en fait qu'on se retrouve avec
un adulte un entraîneur seul avec un
joueur sur un terrain une bulle ou voilà
où il serait seul justement et donc où
il pourrait se retrouver face à un
potentiel agresseur ou ou voilà donc
est-ce qu'il y a des choses qui sont
réfléchies de ce point de
vue-là
euh la le le le le principe du du tennis
c'est comme je vous l'ai dit c'est un
c'est un sport nomade individuel et et
la relation et vous vous l'avez vu parce
que j'imagine que vous avez suivi les
les les affaires qui concernaient le le
tennis
euh il est il est souvent le cas où sur
un cours de tennis ça se joue à deux il
y a pas toujours les parents qui sont là
ou d'autres personnes et malheureusement
très souvent l'entraîneur se trouve avec
sa joueuse ou son joueur sur un terrain
et sont seul euh très sincèrement il y a
il y a alors je vous le dis clairement
moi j'ai pas entendu de mesures prises
par la Fédération française de tennis
pour obliger une tierce personne à venir
sur le terrain ou alors enfin en tout
cas je je je je je sais pas si on a les
moyens de faire ça c'estd attendez vous
ne vous entraînez pas tant qu'il y a pas
une trè personne il faut savoir que dans
dans les clubs parfois et c'est pas au
très haut niveau dans des belles
structures que l'entraînement se fait
c'est parfois dans un club le matin très
tôt où il y a personne dans le club où
on se trouve au fond du cours au dernier
cours parce que on a un entraînement à
faire et souvent on est effectivement
confronté à être seul avec son
entraîneur là aujourd'hui moi j'ai pas
de pas de réponse à vous donner pour
pour vous dire écoutez maintenant à
partir de maintenant on va mettre en
place un
dispositif je suis pas sûr qu'on ait les
moyens comme je vous l'ai dit on a des
référents bénévoles je reviens sur le
bénévola parce que si vous voulez
aujourd'hui qu'on aide cette cause il va
falloir qu'on reconsidère le bénévolat
dans dans dans nos clubs parce que si on
leur demande plus on le dit maintenant
et ben on va mettre sur chaque
entraînement de jeune et si vous il y en
a beaucoup d'entraînement de jeunes on
est 1100000 licenciés notre population à
nous c'est 50 % de jeunes ça veut dire
qu'il y a des entraînements de partout
dans tous les clubs si on veut demain
que une tierce personne vienne pour
contrôler un entraînement ce sera
automatiquement un bénévole et il va
falloir qu'on reconsidère son statut
alors nous on est tout à fait conscient
du bénévolat et de l'importance que ça
au sein de ce mouvement sportif he c'est
on essaie de proposer des choses qui
sont réalist
pour faire en sorte que ce qui est
arrivé à Angélique coché ou à d'autres
n'arrive plus jamais au sein d'une
fédération comme la
vôtre a été évoqué justement dans le
cadre de cette commission l'idée d'avoir
un binôme
d'entraîneur est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qui a qui a traversé les débats au
sein de la fédération par
exemple j'ai la réponse vous l'avez dans
dans ce que je vous ai dit au début 200
joueurs vivent du tennis au monde ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui un joueur de
tennis qui est 4 cenè à l'ATP qui est
déjà 400è mondial aujourd'hui il perd de
l'argent il perd 20 à 30000 € par an il
paye son entraîneur il paye ses
déplacements euh et donc ça veut dire
que si vous lui demandez si on demande
maintenant à ces jeunes joueurs à ces
joueur et joueuse d'avoir deux
entraîneurs encore une fois il va
falloir financer les deux entraîneurs et
c'est un c'est un modèle économique
aujourd'hui qu'il faut revoir
complètement alors on est déjà par
rapport à d'autres disciplines sportives
où vous avez sur du foot un entraîneur
pour 12 joueurs 15 joueurs nous on est
déjà à un pour un si on doit passer à
deux pour un euh je vois pas très bien
comment on va pouvoir économiquement
répondre à cette problématique
ok parce qu'il faut pas oublier que les
jeunes aujourd'hui hein on a je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure quand vous
parlez je prends le foot je suis désolé
de prendre le foot mais ou des sports
d'équipes la détection elle est souvent
faite par les clubs les clubs qui vont
apper les jeunes joueurs pour les amener
en formation nous aujourd'hui c'est la
Fédération on a la chance d'avoir une
fédération qui a des moyens sportifs
donc on a des équipes techniques
régionales on entraîne des jeunes mais
malgré tout dans un club on n'entraîne
pas que tous les champions dans un club
quelqu'un qui veut avoir un cours de
tennis un jeune joueur qui veut un cours
de tennis souvent c'est le club qui
l'aide à financer et souvent ce sont les
parents donc si vous dites maintenant
moi je veux bien que ma petite fille ou
mon petit garçon joue au tennis mais il
faut deux entraîneurs donc je vais vais
vous payer deux
entraîneurs
difficile j'entends mais on vous pose
des questions puisque c'est des
propositions qui ont qui ont été faites
dans le cadre de cette commission
d'enquête donc notamment par angéque
Kochi donc on vous pose la question je
reviens un tout petit peu en arrière
juste en en complément donc à un moment
donc les les jeunes joueurs détectés
rentrent au Pôle France et puis ensuite
au au centre national d'entraînement et
là donc on a on a en place des cellules
autour du joueur donc c'est une équipe
en fait qui travaille autour du joueur
donc c'est c'est plus tard dans le dans
dans la progression mais mais on a
vraiment une équipe avec bah du mental
avec un préparateur physique et cetera
et des entraîneurs et donc dans ce cadre
là le joueur a des à à des entretiens
réguliers avec bah avec l'équipe qui
s'occupe du mental et donc à des moments
en fait où il peut s'exprimer de manière
complètement
indépendante très bien alors juste juste
je vais revenir un tout petit peu en
arrière parce que vous avez indiqué que
parfois certaines victimes étaient venu
vous voir
directement concernant leur leur
signalement comment vous avez procédé
par la suite vous avez fait est-ce que
vous avez fait des signalements en fait
quel est le processus ou le le process
une fois que vous avez un signalement
qui vous
arrive alors très concrètement le
process immédiatement j'ai donc informé
la cellule intégrité chez nous donc
carrément au féissoudre qui a
immédiatement fait un double travail
d'abord attendre que la personne vienne
euh parce que c'était aussi à sa demande
de dire est-ce que je suis prête ou pas
prête je vais pas rentrer dans le détail
si si vous le permettez ici mais euh
puisque c'est quelqu'un qui s'est confié
à moi euh et signaler donc le
signalement a été fait immédiatement par
offhéissoudre sur ce ce cas ce cas de
figure là euh derrière euh le le le la
la machine s'est mise en route donc
signal sport chez nous au féliissou en
attente d'aide et d'accompagnement la
personnaliser pour que la la personne
vienne ce qui a été le cas alors ça a
pris
peut-être je sais pas mais de moisu PRS
vous puissiez préciser un peu est-ce
qu'on parle d'une agression sexuelle de
quoi est-ce qu'on parle exactement sans
rentrer dans le détail et est-ce que
vous avez fait un article 40 on on on on
parle d'une d'une d'une
agression d'un problème d'entraîneur
avec une avec une joueuse donc oui euh
le signalement alors derrière moi j'ai
donc transmis à la celluleintégrité à
Ophé sououdre qui a elle fait toutes les
démarches dont dont vous parlez sur ce
casadre Précis derrière il y a eu la
volonté de de cette victime de venir
s'exprimer auprès de de la fédération et
de et de déjà travailler ce qui est le
cas puisque je pense qu'on a aussi dans
ce cas de figure là mis en place les les
procédures qui sont en cours
actuellement donc il y aura tu peux en
dire un petit mot savoir où ça en est et
puis et puis derrière le signalement a
été fait la personne s'est exprimée et
puis et puis voilà le dossier est en
cours
maintenant euh pour compléter donc la
cellule réceptionne en fait le le le
signalement donc le président s'adr
s'adresse à à la cellule intégrité qui
ensuite va contacter la victime pour
essayer de comprendre savoir comment
est-ce qu'on peut l'accompagner donc ça
c'est une première chose et ensuite il y
a un traitement au cas par cas donc si
c'est une violence si c'est une VSS en
fait c'est transmis à Signal sport donc
on on on travaille avec eux évidemment
et après bah toujours au cas par cas on
déclenche un article 40 et puis on on
fait une saisine de la la Commission
fédérale des litiges en fait on on
enclenche le processus et c'est vrai
qu'on est toujours face bah ce
questionnement en fait des différents
temps le temps administratif le temps
judiciaire voilà les temps le temps des
enquêtes et cetera et donc on est dans
quel cas vous ne faites pas d'article 40
bah alors ça ça dépend si c'est euh en
fait euh il il faut vraiment regarder au
cas par cas on a euh on a des euh
comment dire euh on a des des sujets
parfois qui sont complexes il faut qu'on
comprenne aussi on écoute beaucoup les
les victimes en tout cas qui euh qui
souvent non ont euh on ont des comment
dire des des des questionnements besoin
de plus d'informations et cetera mais on
fait mécaniquement des articles 40 puis
que c'est notre responsabilité de le
faire c'est voilà en fait comme vous
avez indiqué vous ne le faisiez pas
systématiquement c'est pour ça que je
voulais savoir dans quel cas euh vous ne
les faites pas parce que il me semble he
après c'est là aussi on a constaté des
différences entre entre fédérations qu'à
partir du moment où vous recueillez un
témoignage sans forcément d'ailleurs
rentrer dans un processus d'enquête
puisque c'est pas voilà là après on
rentre dans d'autres d'autres
considérations mais le rôle c'est de
signaler de faire un article 40 et
et de laisser ensuite soit le ministère
des Sports en lien avec la justice et la
police mener l'enquête alors dans dans
tous les cas de VSS on fait un article
40 ce que j'ai là où j'ai pas été assez
précise c'est que nos signalements
peuvent faire référence à une insulte
par exemple peut faire référence à une
raquette cassée par par voilà par un
jeune et cetera donc c'est mais dans
tous les cas de VSS ont fait un article
40 merci euh maintenant je voudrais
peut-être aborder avec vous la question
du contrôle d'honorabilité parce que
c'est aussi quelque chose dont on a
énormément entendu parler dans le cadre
de cette commission d'enquête comment se
passent les contrôles
d'honorabilité au sein de votre
fédération euh est-ce que c'est voilà
est-ce que vous arrivez à le faire pour
tout le monde ou enfin voilà
expliquez-nous comment vous vous faites
ces contrôles
d'honorabilité alors les contrôles
d'honorabilité déjà sont effectués pour
les bénévoles les arbitres les juges
arbitres les encadrants bénévoles et et
les dirigeants donc c'est c'est la
manière dont on fait on travaille avec
le le si honorabilité donc des pouvoirs
publics et donc on leur envoie des
fichiers donc on fait des on fait des
campagnes en fait de contrôle
d'honorabilité on a fait une campagne de
de
30000 de de 30000 personnes l'année
dernière et donc on bah on leur envoie
des fichiers euh il y a bah une analyse
qui est fait par les pouvoirs publics et
ensuite le ministère des Sports nous
renvoie donc les les résultats des
contrôle d'honorabilité on a l'année
dernière faite préciser donc vous avez
fait un contrôle d'honorabilité sur
30000 bénévolesou tout à fait c'était
sur les 100000 qui qui sont au sein de
la fédération alors ils sont pas tous
encadrant et jarbitre et cetera donc ça
c'était l'année dernière on a fait c'est
c'est donc c'est assez techniique hein
oui mais en fait je vous demande de
préciser parce que justement là aussi on
a eu des des réponses très différentes
entre le fait que ça soit obligatoire
pour tout le monde ou est-ce que c'est
par cercle de d'encadrement pas
d'encadrement et cetera donc il y a une
liste qui fait des préconisations donc
nous c'est les bénévoles les arbitres
les jugesarbitres les encadrants en fait
tous les
oups voilà donc nous ça c'est c'est
l'année dernière c'était donc c'était
une campagne qu'on a lancé on a eu des
des problèmes techniques en fait de de
référencement de fichiers de de mise en
en commun et et là donc on lance une une
campagne avec 67000 donc acteur donc là
ça va être c'est c'est en train d'être
lancé là
donc c'est la manière dont ça se
passe ou peut-être ouais peut-être pour
expliquer parce que je vousi on vous a
donné un chiffre de 100000 bénévoles et
et vous vous notez qu'on a que 30000
contrôles c'est ça ou 40000 en 2024 pour
être très précis ce qu'on va faire
pardon on a non en fait c'est parce que
je enfin d'abord je ti dire que on vous
demande des précisions d'une part parce
que vous êtes sous serment et donc c'est
important que vous soyez précis dans les
éléments que vous donnez dans le cadre
de cette commission d'enquête mais
surtout parce qu'on essaie de comprendre
puisque en fait les entre les
différentes personnes qu'on a auditionné
personne ne définit le contrôleilité de
la même manière il y en a qui nous
disent c'est obligatoire pour tout le
monde il y en a qui indiquent c'est par
cercle d'encadrement ou pas donc c'est
juste pour savoir s'il y a une règle et
donc qui vous vient du ministère des
sports sur la manière dont doit faire un
contrôle d'honorabilité et quelles sont
les règles précisément qui encadrent ce
contrôle
d'honorabilité alors je vais pour être
précis comme ça je vais lire très
clairement ce que ce qu'on ce qu'on a
fait donc je v dire on a 30000 personnes
qui ont été qui ont été ciblé déjà alors
je dis bien ciblé donc c'est c'est
important parce que par rapport à vous
dans dans un quand vous connaissez le
fonctionnement de nos associations dans
un bureau un comité direct acteur vous
avez un trésorier des gens qui n'ont
aucune aucun contact avec avec des des
jeunes ou avec des relations donc je
pense qu'on a
ciblé sur les personnes qui sont en
contact on parlait d'arbitre et cetera
et et je crois que tu tu as un chiffre
plus précis que moi c'est 77000 c'est ça
67000 cette année 67000 cette année donc
voilà on a l'objectif en 2024 comme
Caroline vous l'a dit on a fait deux
contrôles d'honorabilité ont été faits
la saison dernière hein donc sur ces
personnes on a dû refaire le premier
contrôle pour des raisons techniques on
vous l'a dit un nouveau contrôle
d'honorabilité sera lancé a été lancé en
début de saison 2324 donc d'ici fin
novembre on aura fini on sera capable de
donner des chiffres précis eu ce ce
contrôle va être effectué annuellement
il est réalisé sur la base des licenciés
exerçant des fonctions entrant de l'
champ d'application du contrôle
d'honorabilité donc ça veut dire que on
respecte qu'il y a un champ aujourd'hui
qui a été défini nous le contrôle est
fait dans le cas cadre de ce
champ les premiers contrôles donc a été
difficile à mettre en œuvre je vous l'ai
dit car on avait un problème de qualité
de la données entre les exigences et les
critères qui ont été fixés deonorabilité
les renseignements dans notre base de
lic juste pardon le premier contrôle il
a été fait en quelle année qui a été qui
a été difficile
euh je pense qu'il a été fait sur la
saison précédente d'accord je je pense
hein là j'ai et et avant cela donc par
que contrôle
d'honorabilité il a été mis en place à
partir de quelle année moi j'en ai
entendu parler l'année dernière mais
peut-être qu'il existait avant en tout
cas ce contrôle d'honorabilité nous on
l'a mis en place récemment voilà très
clairement donc comme je dis le premier
contrôle a été difficile donc l'exigence
des critères qui étaient demandés et la
qualité de notre base de données de
licencier et ce sujet donc a été
maintenant largement traité depuis le
dernier
contrôle pour répondre à votre question
aussi lors du premier contrôle alors le
premier contrôle euh quatre personnes
ont été
identifiées d'accord à ce jour ces cas
n'ont pas fait l'objet de procédurees
disciplinaire car chaque cas a était
analysé et contrairement à ce que
faisait ressortir le croisement des
fichiers ces personnes n'exerçaient pas
plus de fonction d'encadrement dans les
clubs concernés étit sorti des effectif
voilà c'est précis alors je vais vous
demandais de repréciser je sais pas si
tout le monde a bien compris ce que vous
voulez dire donc quand vous avez fait le
premier contrôle d'honorabilité quatre
personnes ont été identifiées dans le
cadre de ce contrôle d'honorabilité et
donc elles étaient plus en poste ou
elles étaient en poste mais pas en tant
qu'encadrant ben voilà donc
effectivement donc je je je vous relis
très précisément parce que ce sujet
effectivement av été préparé faisait
ressortir le croisement des fichiers ces
personnes n'exercèent pas ou plus de
fonction d'encadrement dans les clubs
concernés où étaient sortis des
effectifs plus
licencié alors Monsieur
bchon il faut
éteindre vot bonjour monsieur le
Président Madame la Directrice Générale
bonjour Stéphane bchou député de vandet
et membre de cette commission
d'enquête je reviens sur la question
effectivement du contrôle
d'honorabilité pour essayer de de de
bien
comprendre j'avais plusieurs questions
vous y avez peu ou prou répondu dans
votre dernier propos première question
c'est les critères qui concourent à la
mise en place de ce contrôle
d'honorabilité au sein de votre
fédération est-ce qu'ils émanent d'un de
directif du ministère des sports ou
est-ce que le cahier des charges si je
puis le dire ainsi est établi par la
Fédération ça c'est la ma première
question ma deuxème question par rapport
au premier contrôle qui a été effectué
dans dont vous venez de nous parler
récent a priori je voulais savoir
combien de personnes avaient été
identifié priori vous venez d'y répondre
vous venez de nous dire
quatre la question qui suit c'est quelle
sanction pour ces quatre personnes et
est-ce qu'au sein de la fédération vous
avez mis en place justement un barê
enfin pas un barê mais une échelle de
sanction par rapport à ce que vous
pourriez découvrir suite à ce contrôle
de norab
et d'ailleurs moi je m'étonne
qu'effectivement de ce que vous venez de
nous dire puisque quatre personnes ont
été identifiées et qu'à
priorie à l'heure où on se parle elles
n'ont fait l'objet d'aucune d'aucune
sanction et pour autant si elles ont été
identifié c'est bien qu' s'est passer
quelque
chose donc ça m'amène une réflexion plus
qu'à une question
de la
qualité du contrôle d'objectivité
qualité peut-être sur quantitat so
qualitatif et est-ce que est-ce
qu'éventuellement vous avez envisagé de
vous faire
accompagner
par un un un organisme extérieur je ne
sais pas par rapport à à la découverte
et aux sanctions à prendre par rapport à
à ce que vous à ce qui est découvert
suite à à ces contrôles de
nabilité je je
répond donc donc concernant le le
contrôle d'honorabilité donc on on
travaille avec le alors nous on appelle
ça le si honorabilité donc c'est le si
honorabilité des pouvoirs publics donc
la manière dont ça se passe c'est qu'on
envoie nos système d'information
honorabilité donc ils ont il y a un
outil en fait au pouvoir public et donc
on envoie en fait notre fichier avec bah
voilà on envoie notre base de données au
pouvoir public qui l'analyse en fonction
des des critères donc c'est les critères
des pouvoirs publics qui vont ensuite
nous renvoyer les résultats donc ça
c'est c'est euh c'est la manière dont on
fonctionne aujourd'hui si jamais on
avait eu bah des des des cas identifiés
euh en fonction dans dans encore en
fonction dans dans dans nos clubs on
aurait en fait sollicité bah le euh bah
déclencher une procédure disciplinaire
et puis bah pris des mesures à titre
conservatoire donc ça c'est c'est c'est
le le le processus qu'on a en place
mécaniquement je dirais à la Fédération
ouis ah pardon
ouais j'entends hein c'est c'est c'est
intéressant pour pour reprendre ce que
dit Madame la rapporteur c'est
qu'effectivement au au sein de cette
commission on est à la
fois évidemment très
intéressé pour le dire de cette
manière-là de de des faits qui peuvent
avoir s'être passés et et et comment
effectivement tout ça s s'est enchaîné
mais il faut aussi qu'on comprenne
euh au niveau des outils qui sont
aujourd'hui mis en place pourquoi ils ne
sont pas euh on va dire très efficient
au sein d'un certain nombre de
fédérations donc si par rapport à ma
question sur les sanctions vous me dites
Madame la Directrice générale qui a
qu'il est écrit très clairement euh une
échelle de sanction moi je je voilà j'ai
j'ai pas de j'ai j'ai pas de sujet
euh simplement les faits dont on est en
train de parler sont quand même des
faits graves et et l'objectif c'est
quand même que ça ne se reproduise pas
et donc il faut que on puisse
identifier les
dysfonctionnements et et et l'impression
que ça me donne he je je sans sans
porter de sans porter de jugement de
valeur l'impression que ça me donne
c'est que
euh en
fait il faut faire ce contrôle
d'honorabilité donc on le fait mais euh
bon ensuite c'est c'est ça ça ça ça
tombe un peu euh au niveau euh de de de
la suite qui qui est à donner au à ce
qu'on pourrait découvrir donc je moi ça
me laisse un goût un peu d'inachevé
entre
guillemets euh alors déjà on n'est pas
dans le on se dit pas il faut faire le
contrôle dehonorabilité c'est quelque
chose qui est euh qui est complémentaire
en fait parce qu'on a quand même aussi
tous nos enseignantsin et tous nos
enseignants ont leur cartes euh
professionnel contrôlé euh par les clubs
et cetera donc ça c'est euh c'est c'est
c'est une instruc tion qui est donné de
contrôler les les alors comment c'est
contrôlé justement tu veux répondre
c'est dans les clubs c'est prcis
dans oui dans dans les clubs on a on a
l'obligation d'afficher les cartes
professionnelles donc aujourd'hui pour
enseigner et pour encadrer le tennis on
est obligé d'avoir dans le club afficher
la carte professionnelle qui dit carte
professionnelle
dit honorabilité en tout cas dans ce qui
nous concerne aujourd'hui donc ça c'est
fait quand on parle du contrôle
d'honorabilité pour nous il concerne les
bénévoles
encadrant qui sont qui peuvent être dans
dans dans les clubs toute la partie
entraîneur est déjà contraîné de façon
professionnelle donc là on peut mais que
en fait le le contrôle professionnel
est-ce que vous pouvez nous préciser en
quoi ça consiste est-ce qu'on vérifie
par exemple le casier judiciaire est-ce
qu'on vérifie le fichier figess est-ce
que voilà est-ce que vous pouvez nous
préciser ce
contrôle alors la carte professionnelle
le le contrôle carte professionnelle est
complète alors je je suis désolé je peux
pas aller dans le détail de de tout ce
que vous veneez de dire mais je pense
que si on affiche cette carte
professionnelle c'est c'est aussi un un
un un en souci de de l'honorabilité et
ce qui nous concerne aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir enseigner auprès de de jeunes
j'imagine parce que si jamais c'était
pas le cas ce serait compliqué mais on
aura probablement un complément
d'information vous don exactement les
contrôles qui sont effectués sur cette
carte professionnelle qui n'est pas
délivrée par la Fédération Française de
Tennis
très bien bah oui ça serait intéressant
que vous nous envoyez euh en quoi
consiste exactement le contrôle des
cartes professionnelles pour qu'on sache
comment estce que cela est réalisé alors
peut-être une question sur
l'accompagnement des victimes donc euh
euh notamment le fait de vous porter
partie civil au côté de la victime déjà
est-ce que c'est systématique euh ça
première question deuxièmement il est
précisé en tout cas c'est ce qui nous a
été dit c'est que pour que la pour que
vous puissiez vous porter partie civile
il faut que la personne était licencié
au moment des faits et jusqu'à 5 ans
après je crois que c'est à peu près ça
qui est précisé est-ce que vous pouvez
nous indiquer pourquoi cette limitation
dans le temps quand on sait
euh pour la prise en charge voilà
exactement quand on sait que de
nombreuses victimes en tout cas qu'on a
reçu ici ont témoigné plutôt 10 15 15 20
ans après les fait soit en lien avec de
l'amnésie traumatique soit en lien avec
d'autres choses donc voilà est-ce que
vous pouvez nous préciser comment ça se
fait ce cet accompagnement juridique des
victimes euh donc moi j'ai j'ai pas
cette je sais pas où vous avez eu cette
information
donc vous dire que
donc donc c'est dans le cadre de son
activité hein et donc il faut que la
personne a été licenciée au moment des
faits donc ça c'est quelque chose
d'important et qu'il ou elle a été
licencié moins de 2 ans avant le dépôt
de sa plainte donc ça c'est ça c'est le
le cadre en terme de de de temps et
ensuite j'ai j'ai passé 5 ans donc et la
manière dont on les accompagne donc on a
une une garantie donc je crois qu'Ang
Cochi av évoquer des montants donc c'est
c'est pas tout à fait ces montants en
terme de on a on a souscrit une
assurance et et donc ce qui permet la
prise en charge des frais donc tout ce
qui est honoraire nécessaire à toute
action en justice dépôt de plainte
jusqu'à l'exécution de la décision de
justice euh et donc on a on a un maximum
de 20000 € en fait pour pour chaque pour
chaque victime et euh et donc une prise
en charge aussi des d'un accompagnement
psychologique alors nous ces 5 ans c'est
Madame Kochi qui nous en a fait part
donc c'est l'information qu'elle a eu
donc peut-être à reboucler aussi euh en
interne sur la procédure exacte euh
quand vous indiquez jusqu'à faut être
licencié jusqu'à 2 ans avant le dépôt de
la plainte euh est-ce que justement il y
a des réflexions pour assouplir euh ces
règles ou pas du tout par que comme je
vous le disais comme il y a des victimes
qui témoignent de très nombreuses années
après les faits elles peuvent ne plus
être licenciées depuis une dizaine
d'années déjà au moment où où elle
témoigent donc est-ce que c'est des
choses qui sont en cours de réflexion ou
pas du tout pour le moment vous en êtes
resté à à cela ah si si c'est c'est tout
à fait des choses qui sont alors nous on
a ce on a cette on a on a la chance en
fait d'avoir vraiment une cellule qui
travaille à plein temps sur ces sujets
là donc oui c'est en cours de réflexion
on en discute beaucoup avec bah les
associations avec lesquelles on
travaille qui nous font progresser aussi
hein donc c'est des sujets qui sont en
qui sot en réflexion et qu'on veut
améliorer le plus
possible donc cette assurance est assez
récente puisque c'est on l'a mis en
place en septembre
2022 et donc comme tout tout sujet en
fait à la Fédération on met en place et
puis ensuite on on
améliore merci euh vous avez évoqué tout
à l'heure le pool qui entoure en fait
les jeunes sportifs quand ils
intègrent les clubs à une échelle plus
importanteit quand ils sont euh quand
ils deviennent joueurs professionnels on
va dire je vais le résumer un peu comme
ça on nous a parlé du de la surveillance
médicale réglementaire et alors
maintenant c'est obligatoire pour les
les sportifs est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qui est fait pour tout le monde
chez vous
euh ou pas parce que justement on a là
aussi des informations très
différentes alors alors peut-être vous
expliquer comment comment fonctionne le
tennis c'est un sport individuel on n'a
pas les clubs donc nous nous avons un
système où les les les joueurs sont dans
un club ils sont détectés dans un club
alors là on est en train de parler d'un
d'une d'une tranche qui représente moins
d'un % de de nos joueurs c'est le
parcours vers le haut niveau puisque ces
cellules c'est le parcours alors il
commence dans un club où il est entraîné
comme tout le monde et puis ensuite il
est détecté comme étant en ayant des
aptitudes physiques techniques et cetera
il est il reste dans son club il fait
une fois par mois alors on est dans des
U10 des moins de 10 ans il une fois par
mois il fait un rassemblement dès lors
qu'il fait un rassemblement au sein
d'une un comité départemental ou d'une
ligue il a des un entraînement qui mais
il reste dans son club licencié dans son
club ensuite dans son parcours de sur la
cellule pour revenir sur cette cellule
médical il rentre dans une alors c'est
une pyramide hein on commence on est
très très large sur les U10 et puis
derrière il y a des centres fédéraux
d'entraînement qui sont des centres de
ligue qui sont dédiés à chacun des
territoires où là il a des entraînement
il reste toujours dans son club et il a
des entraînements qui sont à partir de
là il y a un suivi médical en tout cas
un contrôle médical mais qui est déjà
existant dans le tennis on a un médecin
de ligue qui suit l'ensemble des jeunes
et puis dès l'ors qu'il y a des on
commence les rassemblements sur les
centres fédéraux d'entraînement les CFE
et bien là il est il est suivi par un
médecin de Lig ensuite l'étape d'après
c'est les centres nationaux
d'entraînement mais là on est vraiment
on réduit hein puisqu'on en a 23 à
Poitier on en a une dizaine à Paris au
CNE donc là on a déjà réduit
considérable on est à à 14 ans après 14
ans où là ils sont la pris en main
totalement là on a un centre médical au
CNE ici idem à Poitier au crebs de
Poitier où là ils sont encadrés
complètement alors je sais pas si j'ai
répondu à votre question mais en tout
cas le le le alors la question c'est
est-ce que la surveillance médicale
réglementaire est effectué chaque année
comme c'est le c'est la loi enfin c'est
c'est obligatoire pour ces
athlètesl avec justement le
l'accompagnement psychologique la la la
question c'est où on commence parce que
est-ce qu'on commence dès l'âge de 7 8 9
ans où ils sont détectés où ils sont
dans leur club encore dans
l'environnement et ils sont pour
l'instant ils continuent à jouer comme
comme les autres et là ils sont très
nombreux parce qu'ils sont près de
500000 donc dans dans la Fédération
enfin 500000 non il y a moins 500000
licenciés jeunes moins de 20 ans mais
sur des des plus jeunes il y a il y en a
beaucoup dans le tennis et là je vous
réponds non il y a il y a il y a dans le
club il y a je vois pas aujourd'hui le
le suivi médical dont vous parlez
s'effectué il est il est individuel en
revanche dès qu'on commence dès qu'on
monte dans les rassemblements dans les
rassemblements et là on réduit
considérablement le nombre le suivi
médical on parlait d'une cellule
préparation ou accompagnement mental là
ça c'est une cellule qui existe mais qui
existe qu'au niveau même si on a mis en
place dans les territoires des référents
la surveillance médicale réglementaire
concerne le haut niveau donc c'est quand
même précis normalement il y a donc
c'est une fois par an et ça permet
justement d'avoir le volet psychologique
dans ce dispositif qui permet de faire
une évaluation en fait psychologique des
sportifs de haut niveau et dans certains
cas par exemple on a pu identifier des
athlètes qui étent en souffrance
d'ailleurs pour différentes raisons donc
c'est pour ça que voilà c'est
obligatoire une fois par an on sait que
il y a des fédérations où c'est très peu
fait donc ma question en fait elle est
très précise c'est est-ce que est-ce que
chez vous vous le faites la réponse est
oui donc on a un médecin à pleintemps
qui fait partie du comité de direction
de la Direction Technique Nationale
aujourd'hui et on a deux psychologues
qui sont là et qui font partie donc de
ce qu'on appelle la préparation mentale
et qui reçoivent en fait les joueurs
voilà et il y a un suivi qui est fait et
c'est c'est des personnes qui font
partie du comité de direction de la
direction technique nationale il faut
pas il faut pas se voler la face on est
en haut de la pyramide et il y en a très
peu oui nous nous dans le tennis alors
autres je viens comparer à d'autres
d'autres sports nous on a ce système là
où c'est que quand vous arrivez dans ce
à ce niveau-là de vous parlez de de haut
niveau moi je j'aime pas parler de
parcours de haut niveau sur les jeunes
parce que le haut niveau c'est le haut
niveau le parcours c'est de la formation
et lorsqu'on a tendance à à parler de
parcours de haut niveau très tôt à 10
ans 12 ans et cetera on a tendance à à
les à les voir déjà arriver et les
parents également donc c'est plutôt de
la formation en revanche pour nous
Fédération Française de Tennis le nombre
est très limité je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure hein c'est au CREPS de Poitier
où ils sont 23 et à la Fédération je
parle des jeunes hein puce qu'il y a
d'autres il y a les moins jeunes ils
sont une dizaine
oui oui mais c'est bien de de de ces
athlètesl dont il s'agit puisque ça a
été mis en place voilà et donc une fois
par an ils sont censés avoir donc ce
rendez-vous qui englobe toutes les
disciplines et notamment le volet
psychologique c'est pour ça qu'on pose
la question parce que c'est c'est très
différent là aussi d'une fédération à
l'autre et il y a des des sportifs qui
aurait je pense qu'on aurait pu éviter
pas mal de choses si ça avait été fait
comme c'est indiqué dans les textes
h peut-être pour
euh glisser un peu sur d'autres sujets
parce que vous l'avez vu sur cette
commission d'enquête traite de de de
différents euh sujets il y a eu
plusieurs affaires aussi qui ont ont
secouit la Fédération de tennis je pense
notamment à la
question de vente des billets Roland
Garros est-ce que vous pouvez revenir
sur cette affaire euh précisément s'il
vous
plaît alors euh le sujet de la vente des
billets de Roland Garros est arrivé une
première fois sur le tapis dans le cadre
de des élections à la à la gouvernance
euh j'ai été alors je vais même remonter
encore un peu plus loin puisque au tout
début de de ma candidature j'ai été
attaqué sur des la vente de billets au
marché noirs de Roland
Garros auprès de conciergerie
parisienne j'ai été attaqué j'ai été
diffamé il y a eu un procès et la
personne qui qui qui m'a attaqué a été a
été condamné ça c'est le premier sujet
et ensuite est née une deuxième affaire
à la à la fin alors j'ai été élu
président de la ligue au Verne renal
j'ai fait mon mandat et à la fin de ce
mandat je me suis présenté à la
Fédération Française de Tennis il y a eu
une campagne un peu musclée très musclée
même pas très correct et à la fin de la
campagne il y avait il y a eu une date
d'élection qui était prévue en décembre
2020 et mon mon adversaire qui était
Président de la Fédération avant a
souhaité bah se laisser encore un peu de
temps parce que les élections on sait un
petit peu comment ça se passe et j'avais
plutôt un avantage et à ce moment-là a
attaqué m'a attaqué a attaqué la Ligue
au renal pour être très précis sur de de
la vente de billets dans le cadre de
partenariat qui était établi avec des
des sponsors et dans ces dans ces
partenariats qui étaient multiples il y
en avait plusieurs il y avait des places
Roland Garros des places de Roland
Garros ce qui était le cas d'ailleurs
donc ça ça fait l'objet au sein de la
fédération du d'une étude qui a révélé
que beaucoup de fédérations faisaient la
même chose c'est-à-dire qu'on avait des
sponsors et dans les dans le cadre de
ces partenariats dans lequel on avait
une véritable prestation on leur
donnait une présence sur les centre de
ligue sur les championnats de ligue une
présence sur le site internet parfois
des opérations marketing ou de sampling
distribution et puis il y avait des
places sur les événements qui éaient
dans la ligue et des places à Roland
Garos et c'est é fait quasiment dans la
plupart des ligues en France sauf que à
ce moment-là mon prédécesseur a souhaité
m'attaquer moi étant son son son son
rival ça a été fait ça a été ça a été
traité au sein de la
fédération et puis derrière ce
dossier sur ce dossier là d'ailleurs
c'est assez étonnant c'est que on étant
élu après ce dossierl a été discuté
ensemble avec toutes les ligues en
disant bah oui on le fait tous toi tu as
été attaqué probablement parce que tu
étais le le candidat dangereux mais ça a
été fait par l'ensemble des ligues et
toute façon tout à fait normalement et
il a été décidé par l'ensemble des
ligues à l'unanimité de créer ce qu'on
appelle le village des ligues donc dans
mon mandat les ligues toutes les ligues
ont décidé de de faire en sorte que bah
les ligues avaient un leur propre espace
de relations publiqu dans Roland Garros
pour inviter les sponsors et les
partenaires donc on a officiellement
l'ensemble des ligues a validé et donc
tout récemment je vais venir au PNF
puisque c'est là où vous voulez pas du
tout je voulais juste que vous précisiez
pardon vous on pourra aller au PNF mais
quand vous parlez des sponsors justement
et donc des billets qui sont mis à
disposition est-ce que vous pouvez juste
nous préciser quel était le problème
parce que après c'est peut-être moi qui
ai mal compris mais moi ce que j'avais
compris c'est que il y avait des
personnes qui avaient des billets Roland
Garros et d'une valeur par exemple de
100 € ou voilà et qui les revendit
parfois jusqu'à 1000 € donc est-ce que
c'est bien de cela que vous parlez ou
encore c'est autre chose non non ça ça
n'était pas du tout le le sujet
aujourd'hui le sujet c'est que on on on
on je dis on parce qu'il y a plusieurs
ligues j'aiété la seule à être visé mais
on comprend
pourquoi dans les dans les paacketes de
de partenariat qu'on avait avec de la
visibilité dans la ligue des opérations
différentes à chaque fois il y avait et
on vous met à disposition 10 billets 10
billets pour Roland Garos tel jour et à
tel endroit mais comme ça fait pour pour
plein de choses et il y avait il y a pas
du tout de revente au billet le billet
en disant ce billet vaut 10 je le
revends 100 c'était pas du tout le cas
c'était pas du tout le sujet c'était un
partenariat global avec la société X où
la société payait 100 et à l'intérieur
il y avait la visibilité dans la ligue
il y avait du du
partenariat sur sur les les les centres
de ligue et il y avait des billets qui
pouvaient représenter un un package de
de 5 dans dans le le le package à 100
voilà c'est pour vous dire que c'était
pas de de la revente de billets au
billets c'était inclure dans un package
des des des places à Roland Garros au
même titre que certains dans leur Ligue
avait un événement majeur et pouvait
dire j'ai une loge au tournoi de tennis
de Marseille de Lyon j'ai des place je
mets à la disposition de mon partenaire
de ligue 10 places pour qu'il viennent
inviter ses clients mais dans l'espace
de la Ligue alors est-ce que cette
pratique de revente de billets a déjà
été effectuée au sein de Roland Garos et
est-ce que vous en avez eu connaissance
alors je suis un peu allergique au mot
revente de billets parce que ce n'est
pas de la revente de billet c'est c'est
c'est l'intégration de place dans le
cadre de package c'est pas de la revente
de billet c'est qu'il y a pas il y a pas
un marché marché noir de vente de
billets j'ai acheté des billets et je
revends je revends cétait pas le cas du
tout al parce que c'est par exemple
quand elles sont données à des sponsors
ou je ne sais pas à qui d'autrre à des
ligues ou il y a des billets qui ont été
vendus suite
est-ce que ça vous en avez eu
connaissance ou pas alors vous parlez
vous parliez de de de de sujet de
reventere de billets individuels oui de
marché noir donc là on est on est
vraiment sur un marché particulier je
vous pose la question justement alors la
Fédération Française de tenis il y a
quelques années a été a été très très
concerné par ce sujetl aujourd'hui on
est quasiment mais pas concerné du tout
c'est qu'aujourd'hui il y a un système
mis en place à la Fédération avec des
billets nominal
qui fait que on a on a plus ce caslà il
y avait beaucoup effectivement de
revendre de de de place à une époque il
y a plus du tout ce cas de figure là
parce qu'il y a un contrôle nominatif
maintenant maintenant le sujet vous
parlez aussi de revente donc vous parlez
aussi de revente donc ça me rassure on
parle de la même chose j'ai dit il y a
plus de revente c'est ça oui donc il y a
eu il y a eu à une époque oui il y a eu
à une époque effectivement comme
beaucoup d'événements sportifs ce ce ce
cas de figure à la Fédération
aujourd'hui nous n'entendons plus parler
ce ce système
là tu peux peut-être compléter oui
peut-être en complément vous dire donc
le le le l'environnement des des des des
billets de Roland Garos c'est très
contrôlé et également très encadré donc
par rapport au au sujet donc des ligues
et et leur et leurs besoins en fait de
relation publique là-dessus on a mis en
place quelque chose que l'on a appelé le
village des ligues donc le village des
ligues c'est une manière très encadrée
pour les ligues de pouvoir emmener leur
leur partenaire Roland Garros le
deuxième point que le président souligné
concernant les billets les billets sont
tracés en fait et ils sont nominatifs
euh donc aujourd'hui on a un système qui
nous permet jusqu'à 24 he avant le le
jour J de de de pouvoir bah changer le
le nom et euh de la personne qui vient
au stade donc on on est plutôt avancé
sur le
sujet allez-y non juste c'est pas une
question c'est une une observation je
m'intéresse
beaucoup au sport beaucoup le
tennis juste un petit témoignage pour
vous dire que dans le club
qui se situe pas très loin de de mon
domicile je peux témoigner
qu'effectivement il y avait il y a
encore quelques années parce que bien le
président en l'occurrence alors c'est
pas ce que je dis n'est absolument pas
scientifique ni ni objectivé mais ça
peut apporter un peu de un peu d'élément
autant moi je peux avoir un certain
nombre d'interrogation sur sur d'autres
sujets sur celui-là je crois pouvoir
dire parce que je me suis un peu
enseigné au préalable qui avait ou
encore quelques années une sorte
d'imbrogliot sur la vente et la revente
des places pour Roland Garos qui est
quand même un événement extrêmement
important dans notre pays et évidemment
auquel beaucoup de personnes veulent
veulent assister et c'est vrai qu'il y
avait au sein des clubs je crois pouvoir
le dire je parle sous votre contrôle une
forme de frustration chez les jeunes
licenciés de ne pas pouvoir toujours
participer à cet événement au profit
effectivement d'un certain nombre de
partenaires et d'institutionnels et je
le dis sans ambage parfois des élus et
souvent d'ailleurs des élus et je crois
qu'il y a eu un peu de ménage de Faé euh
et donc je voulais aussi le souligner il
faut parfois aussi amener quelques
quelques éléments positifs
voilà tout à fait et c'est pour ça qu'on
on a un spectre très large et on voit
l'évolution aussi et ce qui reste à
parcourir justement pour encore
améliorer les
choses donc j'aiévoqué justement les les
différentes affaires qui ont éclaboussé
votre fédération je vais revenir sur
eu le poste de Madame la Ministre oua
ctera donc qui était de qui est devenue
DG de la FFT quelques mois après son
élection au comité directeur sur votre
liste et
euh peut-être vous nous dirait comment
ça se passe justement les nominations DG
et cetera est-ce que c'est courant après
avoir été nommé au comité de passer DG
euh peut-être nous préciser son salaire
en tant que DG à l'époque et est-ce que
c'est toujours le même salaire
aujourd'hui pour les les pour le déjet
actuel et enfin voilà déjà on va
commencer par ça et puis j'aurais
peut-être d'autres
questions euh la la recherche qui qui
est la la mienne au sein de la
fédération c'est une recherche de
compéten euh comme je vous l'ai dit
l'élection a été très très tendue mon
mon élection a été très tendue voire
même décalée dans le temps puisque je
vous ai dit c'était décembre ça s passé
en février à la dernière minute on a
décalé la date sous prétexte de covid et
il se trouve que
lorsque j'ai été élu j'ai été amené à à
très vite rentrer dedans d'abord le
contexte était tellement conflictuelle
que j'avais j'avais quasiment pas accès
à la Fédération avant et ce qui a
d'ailleurs si je peux aller là-dedans
expliquer la la raison pour laquelle
notre arrivée à la Fédération même si je
fais partie de cette famille là et
depuis très très longtemps a été très
compliqué parce que il y avait il y
avait une telle
agressivité contre nous moi on m'avait
on m'avait décrit comm comme comme le
diable au sein même des salariés à
l'intérieur de la Fédération quand je
suis arrivé j'ai découvert un univers
qui a été qui a été compliqué hein
d'abord de se faire
accepter les gens av avaient peur et
donc j'ai été amené à créer mon équipe
très vite et en créant mon équipe aller
à la recherche des des
compétences qui étent qui étaient
indispensable pour mener à bien ma
fédération et il s'est avéré que j'ai et
j'avais dans mes équipes des gens qui
étaient là pour venir aider le tennis ou
qui aidaient le tennis depuis longtemps
et plutôt que d'aller chercher à
l'extérieur j'ai souhaité que ça se
fasse à l'intérieur donc ça a été
effectivement Souain c'était pas prévu
parce que si ça avait été prévu j'aurais
jamais débauché quelqu'un au sein de mon
propre Comex je l'aurais mis de côté
j'aurais dit attends tu tu te mets de
côté et puis tu viens derrière donc j'ai
pensé que Amélie ouia Castera était la
bonne personne pour pour diriger la
Fédération elle avait été joueuse
professionnel elle avait arrêté le
tennis à un moment donné où elle était
au au niveau d'Amélie moresmo qui était
numéro 1 mondial vainqueur d'un grand
schlem elles étaient ensemble elles
jouaient en double pour la petite
histoire à Roland Garros toutes les deux
et une a dit bah moi je continue améie
moresmo et Amélie ou ctera a dit B moi
je je pense que je suis pas fait pour ça
donc je vais partir sur les études vous
connaissez son parcours maintenant donc
je je l'ai choisi elle est rentrée donc
avec moi à la
Fédération derrière j'ai été amené à
alors euh à a donc à à évalué la
rémunération qui était la sienne déjà
dans l'entreprise dans laquelle elle
était hein elle était dans une
entreprise où elle touchait si on
cumulait les stock options et cetera
elle était à de de mémoire à 100 mil00on
et demi par an si je cumulais l'ensemble
et donc la rémunération je suis pas
précis au si vous me permettez on vous
donnera les chiffres mais une
rémunération qui a tourné autour des
400000 € euh donc d'un salaire brut et
ensuite avec un intéressement de mémoire
qui était en fonction des résultats de
la féération de de 100000 € voilà donc
elle a divisé par 3 pour être très franc
et maintenant pour ici j'ai j'ai prêté
serment donc je suis ravi de pouvoir le
faire ici et de ne
pas éluder cette question parce qu'elle
m'a été posée Amélie ouia casterra est
venue à la Fédération Française en
divisant son salaire par 3 voilà donc je
voudrais que les les gens maintenant le
sachent je suis ravi de pouvoir le dire
dans ce contexte là et et donc c'était
pour moi le niveau de rémunération alors
avant nous avions quelqu'un un un
personnage qui avait aussi une
rémunération qui était pas pas très
éloignée de celle-ci je dirais une
bêtise Monsieur Jean-François vilot qui
était directeur général de la Fédération
française avant que j'arrive mais qui
était pas très éloigné on était dans les
mêmes zones donc il y a pas de de
scandal et pour revenir sur Caroline
flessier pour être totalement
transparent on vous donnera des élé
c'est ce que me dit Caroline donc on
pourra vous donner des éléments si si
vous le souhaitez mais pour moi je suis
allé chercher des compétences j'ai
recruté alors la manière dont on l'a
fait je voudrais revenir sur le contexte
2021 est assez particulier puis que
j'arrive il faut diriger cette
fédération je vous rappelle que la
Fédération c'est quasiment 460
équivalent temps plein à la Fédération
plus 800 dans les territoires donc on
parle on parle d'une d'une entreprise
d'une véritable entreprise qu'il fallait
quelqu'un qui ait l'expérience pour
pouvoir le faire et puis derrière
Caroline qui elle un parcours au sein de
de de grands groupes français me
semblait et pas forcément joueuse de
tennis en tout cas joueuse jeune joueuse
pas le niveau d'Amélie ou deacassera
mais le niveau en reggence de la de la
direction générale pour diriger une
fédération comme la mienne voilà donc
euh je suis ravi de pouvoir apporter ces
informations et vous apporter ces
informations merci pour ces tous ces
éléments peut-être du coup euh vous
pourrez nous transmettre euh les autres
informations complémentaires donc le DG
précédent et vous en l'occurrence bon
vous n donnez pas ici c'est normal il y
a pas de souci mais vous pourrez nous
transmettre tout cela euh peut-être euh
est-ce que vous pourriez revenir sur Al
pas revenir du coup nous préciser parce
qu'on a eu aussi visiblement cette année
la Fédération aurait fait l'acquisition
d'un bien immobilier euh est-ce que vous
pouvez nous revenir là-dessus et donc
nous expliquer euh euh alors pour
pourquoi l'achat de ce bien pour qui et
peut-être aussi à qui il appartenait et
le montant de l'acquisition
merci mais je crois qu'on avait une donc
on a une stratégie patrimoniale au sein
de la fédération donc vraiment une
stratégie propriétaire Président vous en
a parlé avec nos tournois mais mais pas
que puisque on est également
propriétaire d'un de de bureau à
Boulogne et et donc en en regardant et
en analysant nos dépenses comme on fait
comme on fait tout le temps chaque jour
on s'est aperçu que des il y avait
énormément donc de de de comment dire de
sommes qui étent alloué à la location
pour loger le président et et donc dans
ce cadre là en fait on a on a on a pris
la décision de faire l'acquisition de
l'appartement dans lequel le président
que le président louait c'était vraiment
suite à une voilà les les locataires en
fait ont mis l'appartement en vente et
donc bah comme tout locataire on nous en
a informé on s'est posé la question à ce
moment-là et ça rentrait bien dans notre
stratégie
patrimonial un complément d'information
sur toute la
question Caroline a a répondu sur
l'aspect patrimonial de la Fédération on
a effectivement la chance de pouvoir
être propriétaire de de de pas mal de
voire même de de ligue de centre de
ligue et on investit beaucoup on a un
parc qui est ass c'est assez important
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé concrètement
j'ai aussi de précis sur des chiffres
j'arrive à la Fédération et mon
prédécesseur donc il y a une liste
civile dans la fédération qui est une
enfin une obligation tu vois qui est qui
est comme ça avec un certain nombre
d'avantages pour le président dont la
possibilité de d'avoir des déjeunés
d'avoir un appartement il y a une
voiture et un un chauffeur qui est mise
à la disposition de la Fédération il y a
un salaire qui est envisagé par le pour
le président de la Fédération d'ailleurs
dans les statuts on peut même aller plus
loin c'est un sujet important puisque on
peut imaginer que des présidents de
ligue des des des président de club en
tout cas dans No statti ont la
possibilité d'être indemnisé d'e
indemnisation plutôt que d'une
rémunération ce qui était le cas donc
moi dans la liste civile j'ai la possib
je suis logé quand quand je suis à Paris
et donc mon prédesseur lui avait une
chambre d'hôtel à l'année et mes
prédécesseurs c'est important de le
savoir mes prédécesseurs puis qu'il y a
eu avant Jean Gachassin réservait dans
dans un hôtel à l'année une chambre qui
coûtait alors mon prédécesseur c'est je
connais le chiffre précisément c'était
58000 € à l'année est-ce qu' coûtait à
la Fédération et moi j'ai regardé ce
chiffre et j'ai dit mais 58000 €
je travaille beaucoup je passe 10 heur
par jour à la Fédération quasiment toute
la semaine je retourne en Provence en
province de temps en temps où où ma
femme vient de temps en temps à Paris et
j'ai dit moi je me vois pas vivre dans
une chambre d'hôtel tout le temps donc
je préférais le louer et ça va coûter
moins cher donc on a cherché un
appartement à Boulogne et on a a trouvé
un appartement qui a coûté à qui coûtait
à la Fédération à l'année on vous
donnera pareil les précisions de mémoire
32000 € par par an au lieu des 58000 et
j'ai trouvé que c'était mieux d'avoir un
appartement alors il fait 70 m² de vivre
là-dedans alors cette appartement
comment je l'ai trouvé d'abord on a
aussi des traces de visiter j'ai visité
plusieurs appartements dans Boulogne
celui-là m'a été présenté par un ami qui
me dit mais Gill tu cherches un
appartement pour loger à Boulogne j'ai
euh
mes mes enfants qui ont hérité puisque
leur maman est décédée tout récemment
ont hérité d'un appartement tu veux
aller le voir je vais le voir et cet
appartement est absolument remarquable
est à deux pas de de Roland Garros et
donc je prends je dis bah c'est celui-là
c'est le moins cher des des autres je
vais prendre cet appartement là donc les
fameux 32000 je suis dans l'appartement
tout va bien je passe 2 ans et au bout
de 2 ans la la la fille une des filles
parce qu'ils sont trois enfants vient
dire nous on veut vendre l'appartement
et là je me retourne vers la Fédération
et je dis écoutez voilà de toute façon
la Fédération a une politique
patrimoniale et puisque ça a été ensuite
voté en assemblée générale on a on a
demandé à nos élus de de de se prononcer
sur l'acquisition d'un bien et de
renforcer le patrimoine de la fédération
en expliquant qu'on avait effectivement
à Boulogne aussi acheté un hôtel
particulier on parlait de bureau mais
moi je vais parler d'un hôtel
particulier parce qu'on a à peu près une
centaine de personnes qui sont à deux
pas de Roland Garos parce qu'on avait
pas c de place classe dans Roland Garros
et que en l'espace de 10 ans ou 15 ans
on a fait une plus-value assez
incroyable sur l'acquisition de ce bien
et on a pensé et d'ailleurs avec une
appréciation de nos commissaires aux
comptte quand on a pris cette décision
c'était un bon choix patrimonial pour la
Fédération d'avoir acheté cet
appartement donc lorsqu'on a lorsque les
propriétaires m'ont dit on s'en va j'ai
j'ai effectivement sollicité la
Fédération euh pour l'acquisition de ce
bien voilà comment les choses se sont
passées alors euh
oui juste vous n'avez pas répondu à à à
ma question c'està dire le montant de
cette
acquisition peut-être aussi vous devez
avoir son estimation et à combien vous
l'avez acheté par rapport à l'estimation
au prix du marché
et si vous pourrez aussi nous préciser
parce que tout à l'heure vous avez
indiquer 400 millions de chiffre
d'affaires pour la Fédération donc cela
n'inclut pas le patrimoine juste pour
préciser alor je vais même aller plus
loin alors je laisser Caroline répondre
à ça mais si le patrimoine qui est le
nôtre si on devait valoriser le tournoi
de Rolland Garos valoriser le Relx Paris
Masters le patrimoine de la Fédération
ser très très important et effectivement
ce n'est pas valorisé donc aujourd'hui
je pense que nos actifs immobiliers le
sont je pense je laisserai Caroline
répondre mais sur le reste bien plus
important que nos patrimoinees
aujourd'hui le tournoi de roll fa savoir
que dans dans le tennis ce sont des
dates qui se vendent euh très récemment
euh je vais parler du rellex Paris
Masters qui démarre là dans dans 2 jours
enfin qui a demain pour les
qualifications euh cet événement fait
partie d'une catégorie de tournoi hein
il y a un niveau c'est un Masters 1 il y
en a un qui s'est vendu il y a pas très
longtemps à Madrid euh autour de 300 à
400 millions d'euros euh nous sommes
mastermal non pas combine c'estàd hommes
et femmes il y a que des hommes faute de
place si nous avions plus de plac nous
fions nous ferions comme à Roland Garros
les hommes et les femmes mais euh
effectivement le le pat
moine ne tient pas compte de ses valeurs
et je parle même pas de Roland Garos qui
est aussi un événement mais l'immobilier
je pense que l'immobilier fait partie de
et donc la réponse sur le prix d'achat
de l'appartement alors
moi alors il y a eu effectivement
plusieurs agences qui sont venus voir
effectivement l'appartement il y a eu
plusieurs valorisations qui ont été fait
entre
800 900 1 million un peu plus d'un
million et nous l'avons acheté 1 million
voilà je me trompe pas 1 million c'est
ça on sera
voilà merci donc pareil ça là de la même
manière on vous enverra les les chiffres
exacts on peut vous communiquer
également les les devis qu'on a eu des
différentes agences concernant le le
patrimoine et la manière dont on le les
femes fameux 400 millions dont dont le
président vous parlait était notre
chiffre d'affaires ensuite on peut vous
communiquer les les bilans et en effet
nous sommes propriétaires donc du
tournoi de Rolland Garros et du tournoi
du Relx Paris Master et puis d'autres
tournois plus régionaux et et nous avons
également des licence d'exploitation
voilà alors est-ce que
euh vous alors est-ce qu'il y a des
choses qu'on a'urait pas abordé que vous
souhaiteriez porter à la connaissance de
cette commission puisqu'on arrive sur la
fin
moi je suis désolé je vais revenir sur
mon sujet des
bénévoles je crois que c'est un sujet
important pour le sport français notre
sport vit par des bénévoles moi si je me
suis lancé là-dedans à la
retraite c'est parce
que c'est parce que j'avais envie de
rendre au tennis que le tennis m'avait
apporté c'est toute ma vie mais à un
moment donné il faut que qu'on considère
et notamment dans le cadre de votre de
votre mission aujourd'u aujour'hui et
commission il est important de de
comprendre que si on doit s'appuyer sur
des gens parce que le problème il est on
a des cas qui situe en haut mais on a
sûrement des cas qui se situent en bas
et ce sont nos bénévoles au quotidien à
qui on demande beaucoup qu'il faut qu'il
faut considérer voilà donc si c'est le
message et le sujet que c'est surtout
pas éluder le les problématiques que
vous avez évoqué je pense que tout n'est
pas parfait au sein de la fédération
mais qu'on est très très conscient et et
moi le premier on a avec avec Caroline
une tolérance zéro dès qu'un sujet se se
se rapporte à nous et bien on a on a la
volonté de le mener au bout et de et de
répondre réellement à ces problèmes qui
existent et problèmes de société
d'ailleurs merci pour pour votre
disponibilité c'est entendu en tout cas
on l'a bien en tête la question des
bénévoles on sait que il y a 3 millions
de bénévoles aujourd'hui qui sont qui
font vivre ce sport français et euh
justement le l'objectif de cette
commission est bien de faire en sorte
que voilà que les choses s'améliore pour
les professionnels pour les sportifs
pour les bénévoles et surtout que ça
fonctionne correctement donc on a bien
en tête la question des bénévoles merci
à vous merci beaucoup peuvent être
util ils peuvent être utiles c'est eux
qui peuvent être
utiles